[Arabic recitation]
older that, you know, but you
got a nice head of hair, too, you know.
So, you know, either way kind of works
for you.
You know, ,
for the longest time,
I
always wore a hat. I was just always in
the mood. I was so busy.
So, I would just shave my head all the
time because
nobody's going to see it anyways, you
know.
[Arabic recitation]
used to have long hair and I cut it. You
know why? For you guys. I cut it for you
guys. So you don't say, "What kind of
imam is this?" Long hair,
right? It was a Tarzan imam. Well, I
mean, you know, that's what the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam always had
long hair.
The only time his hair was short was
when he would go for Hajj. That's it.
Only time. You know, because especially
in that time, in that culture, hair was
always looked at on men as being,
you know, a a strength, a
presence. You know,
times change. What are you going to do?
[Silence]
Allah subhanahaala
he tells our prophet Sam
and this is chapter number 68 8
and verses 1-4
as a recap he says subhanahu wa ta'ala
that which translates to
I swear
I swear by the pen and all that they
write all that the writers use it to
Right.
You, oh Muhammad, O messenger, are not
in the least bit insane by the grace and
blessing of your Lord.
And indeed I further swear by the pen
and all that
they use to write
they use it to write that for you is
a great and unending
reward.
And indeed I further swear by the pen
and all that it is used to write all
that they write that
you oh messenger are upon
great and esteemed character.
So, we've discussed these
verses
and we've discussed them in some
detail, but I want to just take a moment
here to mention something.
There is a difference between a
systematic
class if you will and a lecture or a
speech.
A lecture or a speech or what they refer
to the scholars refer to as a muhador
right is something that the student or
the listener doesn't really need to
prepare for. you just walk in and listen
to it and understand it right there. But
something this is very important
that you know no matter how skilled the
teacher is, the listener has to do his
part. This is a a relationship here, a
two-way relationship, which means I give
the knowledge, but you also have to seek
it in order for it to in order for it to
set in. And what greater knowledge is
there than that of the book of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala? That's why the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam proclaims
in no uncertain terms
Amen. Is
the best of you are those who learn the
Quran and teach it. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us
[Silence]
He said, "No people, no people meaning
whether it's two people or 200, no group
of people, whether they are slaves or
free men, wealthy or poor, whether they
are the the best or not,
No Muslim man will gather in a house of
the houses of Allah, any house of the
houses of Allah, reciting the book of
Allah and studying it amongst one
another except that the mercy of Allah
will engulf them and the tranquility of
Allah will descend upon them and the
angels will come to that gathering and
surround it with their wings all the way
into the heavens and Allah will mention
those people by name individually in
real time as it is happening. We gather
in the house of Allah doing this right
here. Allah is mentioning us and
mentioning us by name
to the angels that carry his throne, the
angels that are closest to him.
So and so and so and so and so and so
and so they are in such and such house
and they are reciting my words they are
studying my words
that's just the just that's just for
attending
right to the point that the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam mentioned a
group of people
gathered
remembering Allah which is what we they
are doing and the angels come to report
to Allah and he says what are they
asking he said they are asking for your
paradise he said and have they seen my
paradise angels will say no will say how
much more so if they saw it
and what are they seeking refuge of from
say well they are seeking refuge from
your punishment from the hellfire
And Allah will ask, "And have they seen
the hellfire?" They will say, "No." He
said, "How much more so would they beg
if they had seen the hellfire? I forgive
all of them." Then the angels will say,
"Oh Allah, but there is a man amongst
them who's not part of them. He's not
one of them. He just happened to
find himself at that place." You
know, imagine someone who's passing
through just happened to be in the
masid, right? He didn't come for that
purpose. He said,
he said, "Those are people that no one
who sits in their company. It is
inappropriate for anyone who sits in
their company to be of the miserable of
the people of the hellfire." I forgive
him too, just for being there.
just just for being there even because
he didn't intend. This is how important
what we do here is. Don't ever be fooled
by busy work, right? Busy work. Always
the idea is, "Oh my gosh, you guys are
just sitting in the masid all day. All
day." No, not all day. We finished our
dunya and now we're sitting here. The
world is falling apart and you're all
sitting in the masid. Yeah. So if we
leave the masid right now, the world
will be saved. It won't fall apart
anymore if we're not here.
It is time for us to buckle down and
learn this book. Revive it. We come from
hundreds of years, almost 200 years.
Every one of us from every single
country. We come from almost 200 years
of colonialism and slavery. We have been
stripped of our identity. We've been
stripped of our history. We've been
stripped of our religion. We don't even
know our own book anymore. We can't even
read our own book anymore. And so the
buck has to stop with us. It has to.
We cannot afford for one more generation
to be us again. It stops here. Our
children are going to be better than us
and we are going to revive
Allah's religion and the Muslim state in
our hearts. Hopefully, Allah will then
revive it for us in our in our reality.
It's it's been said by some of the
scholars of Islam.
[Silence]
revive the Muslim state in your hearts
truly
and Allah will then revive it for you in
your real world. I know that many of us
are suffering from something because all
of this brainwashing that we come from,
all of this colonialism that we come
from, all of this this real number
that's been done on our heads, every one
of us from every country that we've come
to
come from that we suffer from the
greatest enemy of knowledge and
advancement for the Muslims and the
Muslim state. You know what it is?
Hesitation.
Hesitation only serves to kill.
Hesitation. We're not all the way in the
dunya and we're not all the way in the
we're just we're kind of in this weird
bizarre middle ground. I can't
completely devote myself to the duny
entirely because I'm afraid. But I'm
also can't completely devote myself to
the hereafter because I'm afraid I'm
going to miss out on the dunya. So we
hesitate and what ends up happening? We
miss both.
Imagine with me if you're a hunter and
there's two there's two
you know bucks there or two deer
whatever you're hunting, right?
and you put that deer in your sight and
just as you're going to squeeze the
trigger, another slightly bigger deer
comes out. You look at you say, "Wow,
that guy's looking good. Let me go with
him." And just as you're going to
squeeze the trigger, a third comes out.
That's a little better. And then what's
going to happen if this keeps going on?
you're going to go home hungry. You're
not going to go home with anything.
And so hesitation is what is killing us.
It's killing our dunya
because we don't commit to it entirely.
So we're left behind and it's killing
our because we don't commit to it
entirely. So we're left behind. So we
are the children of who? We are orphan
children. people who neither neither
flourished in the dunya nor in the
hereafter.
And this is why Allah tells us
oh you who have believed enter into
he didn't say Islam
that's what's intended but he didn't say
Islam
what is
submission
Give up the fight. Stop fighting the
light. Stop it. Stop fighting the light.
Stop hesitating.
Every time you go to do something good,
that whisper comes and nags you. Oh,
you're going to do this now, but
tomorrow you have this to do and you
have that to do. You can't pray right
now tomorrow inshallah. And this is what
we keep doing because we give shaitan
today and he promises us tomorrow. And
that's how the relationship has been. So
we we we don't get anything done. We
hesitate. We don't dedicate ourselves to
any one thing entirely and completely.
Allah says, "Enter. Give yourselves into
submission
entirely. Surrender. Surrender. Let go.
Let go."
Try it. Try letting go entirely and and
completely holding to the hereafter.
rack your brain and do as best as you
can for the hereafter. Try it for a
week. Try it for two. A shaitan will
always take you back. If you're if if
not shaitan will always take us back,
right?
Try it. Imagine if we took everything we
did seriously.
Right. I'm in the class. I'm in the
class. I am at work. I'm at work. I'm at
home. I'm at home. And we're present for
the moment. We would rule the earth.
We would. And sometimes we look and we
say, you know, the Muslim are being left
behind. Why is it? Well, we suffer from
a lot of problems. We have a hard time
running even a single masid without
tearing each other to bits. What would
we do to the world if we got a hold of
it? In the ca in the state that we're in
right now, we have to learn submit
ourselves entirely. And it all begins
with the Quran. And I swear there is no
sweetness on this earth greater than
reading, learning, memorizing,
understanding,
and existing with the words of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And there is no
heart pure. And there is no heart more
tranquil. And there is no mind stronger
and there is no will more powerful than
that of a human being who has been given
the book of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
subhanahu wa so basically the the
moral to the story read the verses
before you come in right every day we do
one or two verse read them think
about them ask questions prepare so that
you get what you're coming for bring
must have with you. Open it. Follow
along. There's only so much I can do to
spoon spoon feed. You have to open your
mouth and chew it and take it. Right?
So, we don't want to continue the u
cycle. We want to stop it with us.
[Arabic recitation]